what role
does money play in all this is money
huge influence in politics
uh super pacs all that kind of stuff or
is this
is this more just kind of a narrative
that we play with
because from the outsider's perspective
it seems to have
that seems to be one of the fundamental
problems with modern politics so i was
just having this conversation
marshall and i marshall castle of my
cohost on the realignment and
it's funny because if you do enough
research we
actually live in the least corrupt age
in american uh campaign finance as in
it's never been more transparent it's
never been more
up to the fec yeah and all of that
if you go back and read not even 50
years ago we're talking about lyndon b
johnson handing people
like literally as he came up in his
youth
paying people for votes like the boss of
the
you know the person who like had all the
mexican boats like the person who had
and he was like giving out briefcases
this is like within people's lifetimes
who are alive in america
so that doesn't happen anymore but i
don't like to blame everything on money
although i do think money is obviously
a huge part of the problem i actually
look at it in terms of
distribution um which is that how is
money distributed with an artist within
our society
because i firmly believe that politics
this is going to get complicated but i
think politics is mostly downstream from
culture
and culture obviously i'm using
economics because there's obviously a
huge interplay there but like
in terms of the equitable or lack of
equitable distribution of money within
our politics
what we're really pissed off about is
we're like our politics only seems to
work
for the people who have money i think
that's largely true
um i think that the reason why things
worked differently in the past
is because our economy was structured in
different ways
and there's a reason that our politics
today are very analogous to the last
gilded age
because we had very similar levels
levels of
economic distribution and cultural
problems too at the same time i don't
want to erase that because i actually
think that's what's driving all of our
politics right now
so that's interesting so yeah that's one
so in that sense representative
government is doing a pretty good job of
representing
it is the state of culture and the
people and so on yeah
you